d'accord d'
accord donc l'album s'appelle la magie et
la perte quel est le lien que vous
faites entre ces deux termes j'appelle l'
album la magie et la perte parce que l'album
est un exemple de la façon de gérer la perte
et la capacité de gérer la perte et
le processus  ce qui se produit qui
nous rend possible je pense à la magie que je
pense aussi à la musique comme à la magie
donc c'est la perte quelque chose que vous devenez
vraiment plus riche avec l'âge et sans
le passage du temps je pense que ces
jours-ci en particulier nous tous probablement
vous-même  inclus la perte d'un
ami ou d'un membre de la famille n'est pas si vrai
que c'est vrai, mais cela n'inclut-il pas
également même si ce n'est pas le
thème réel de l'album cela inclut-il
que vous connaissez la perte de choses à travers la
civilisation beaucoup de choses qui
être là et qui sont perdus à travers le
processus de civilisation de plus de charbon de qualité
et suivre que du tout l'
album parle aussi d'amitié et d'amour
et la perte de cette amitié
est que quelque chose que je  a besoin de l'album,
il semble que c'est quelque chose qui est
vraiment important pour ton ami d'avoir une
amitié,
bien sûr, je veux dire, est-ce que tu l'
apprécies comment j'apprécie l'amitié,
il y a tout un album sur les
amitiés, je ne le
ferais pas  le top est-ce quelque chose
qui vous sort et par exemple survit à l'amour
ou est-ce que ça fait partie de la même chose je
pense que ça fait partie de la même chose pour moi
c'est je veux dire ce n'est pas dit dans le au
moins dans cette fois les traductions de Yanam
que nous  mais au moins l'une des
personnes dont vous parlez sur l'
album est censée être l'omus est-ce que quelqu'un
ici regarde comme si je suis brillant
ou quelque chose comme ça
oh est-ce que ce qu'elle fait d'accord
excusez-moi une seconde je viens
Je veux m'assurer que je ne ressemble pas toujours à une
bille blanche, donc la question était
en fait, il a été dit que l'un
des premiers dont vous parlez de
l'analyse doc Pomus le grand doc
Pomus oui grand homme alors quoi  était votre
relation avec salut  m le fait
que c'était un New York basé sur un auteur-compositeur
eh bien, il était bien plus que cela, il était
juste un gars formidable un gars incroyable
incroyable vraiment unique et merveilleux
c'est terrible à ce jour que je ne puisse pas l'
appeler au téléphone de temps en temps  un
moment j'ai écrit autour de l'album
je vais à je vais juste l'appeler pas là
en fait je vais vous raconter une
histoire drôle un groupe d'entre nous après l'
enterrement ils ont dit un groupe de femmes
voulait son frère  et ses enfants de
laisser son répondeur allumé parce que
les femmes aimaient tellement entendre la voix
pour ne pas l'enlever et le
téléphone était utilisé pour nos pieds droits plus
Chu Minh ouais est également décédé j'ai été
interviewé par Mort Shuman il y a 12 ans
avec  quelque chose et il y a quelqu'un
avec eux qui vit ici en
France depuis 10 20 ans
ouais mais pas en tant qu'auteur-compositeur maintenant il a
sa propre écriture d'un autre chanteur mais en tant qu'auteur-
compositeur l'
avez-vous fait et vous sentez qu'il y aurait
quelque chose comme un déclic  de vous kn  ow deux
personnes qui ont écrit des chansons à
New York depuis la fin des années 50 Je
commence à la fin des années 50 et 60 ce
serait très petit nous pourrions tous nous asseoir
à une seule table très petite table qui d'autre
serait là
monsieur King  Ellie Greenwich mhf Barry
Cynthia Weil Barry homme de ce type
ce que je veux dire évidemment à part le
fait que vous êtes de la même ville de la
même région eh bien quel serait l'
esprit commun oh euh je ne sais pas à ce sujet je
ne  Je ne sais pas si nous avons tous un
esprit commun mais s'il y a un fil conducteur
c'est probablement la ville c'est pourquoi j'ai
écrit mon album New York parce que je
pensais que euh je devrais reconnaître que
New York était une personne dans ma vie qu'il
existait comme une personne énorme qui m'affectait
chaque jour d'une manière ou d'une autre
et qui me façonnait et que j'étais un produit de
la ville et que rien de ce que je pouvais faire ne
changerait jamais cela parce que je suis
au moins à la moitié de ma vie
et que la ville m'a affecté  pour tout
cela,
Al Kooper est en fait un autre  sur New
York, l'auteur-compositeur et musicien une fois majeur
n'a jamais écrit une chanson qu'il dirait alors
pouvez-vous me dire le nom de celle que j'étais
sur le point d'écouter juste parce qu'il a dit qu'il avait une
chanson à Hong Kong New York c'est une femme
est-ce que ça a du sens  toi et pas
du tout, je veux dire, je pourrais comprendre que
New York est une femme Les New-Yorkais sont ce
côté de New York qui est Je n'ai jamais pensé à
Al Kooper en tant qu'auteur-compositeur Je l'ai pensé
en tant que claviériste, donc pour ne pas
dénigrer Al Kooper
je veux dire  Je pense qu'il a fait une chanson qui s'appelle des
courts métrages avec les adolescents royaux Je
ne suis pas sûr que vous ne sachiez pas que vous sauriez
mieux que moi pas nécessairement peut-
être ouais mais je ne le considère pas comme un
auteur-compositeur en particulier pensez-vous que
il y a, je veux dire, il semble que
de l'extérieur, il semble qu'il y
ait en fait un fil ou au moins gagné,
vous connaissez une ligne que vous avez
poursuivie qui vous a guidé de
peut-être de plus loin mais au moins
de la  New York album foo chansons
étranger et maintenant au n  nouvel album je
veux dire on dirait que c'est comme affiner
tu sais une sorte de façon d'écrire dans
une ville d'histoire je pense que depuis le tout premier
album il y a eu un fil stylistique
mais ça devient particulièrement apparent et
efficace je pense à partir de l'
album de New York  puis des chansons pour Ella et en ce
moment je pense que dans un saut quantique pour moi
personnellement
stylistiquement et techniquement magie et
perte je ressens une réelle avancée oui la
première ligne avez-vous je veux dire pouvez-vous
réellement vous voir vous savez
aller
mieux  Je pense que pour moi,
plus je pratique quelque chose, plus je m'améliore
et je pratique un certain nombre
de choses depuis un moment maintenant et je pense que
je me suis amélioré, donc je ne sais pas si d'
autres personnes le font mais je  je pense que j'ai
juste voulu donc cela nous rend bien
au moins au moins
deux d'entre nous alors merci à Dieu pour cela
est-ce que je veux dire est-ce que ce fait le rend
plus disons évident que ce devrait
être le moment où  vous décidez t  o publier
un livre réel de vos écrits au fil des
ans c'était une chose fortuite qui
s'est produite c'est quelque chose que
j'aurais aimé faire pendant un bon moment
on ne m'a jamais demandé mais quand on m'a demandé la
personne qui m'a demandé quand nous avons discuté
du livre  dans le genre de livre qui les
intéressait était le genre de livre qui
m'intéressait qui était plus qu'une
simple compilation et ce n'était pas vous
savez avec des images et des
autographes de jouets qui était un vrai livre une vraie
collection de paroles qui  formez
un récit et propulsez-vous comme vous aimez des
années 60 70 80 jusqu'aux années 1990 même ce
livre pourrait être dit que nous recherchons un
éditeur en France d'ailleurs je pourrais
ajouter pensez-vous que nous pourrions le faire
sans que personne n'utilise la salle de bain c'est
pas Audrey ce n'est pas notre chambre qui
va bien parce que vous devriez facturer de l'
argent ils vont le faire je suppose
que sortir les piles devrait être assez
facile de trouver un éditeur en France
l'intéressant des
choses intéressantes est  que nous avons un éditeur en
Allemagne quelqu'un peut-il tirer sur le gars
ils sont très persistants
nous éditons en Allemagne et en Angleterre mais
pas ici
une chose intéressante est que vous avez décidé
d'inclure deux articles journalistiques dont
vous avez fait un avec un gars intelligent dont il était
fan depuis longtemps  le vôtre et celui avec vous
avez un zombie sans mot est quelqu'un qui
a au moins une parenté d'intérêt en
ce qui concerne les sujets qu'il est impliqué et
bien j'ai fait ces interviews parce que
c'était l'occasion de rencontrer deux personnes
que j'admirais vraiment Hubert Selby et
vaclav havel  et c'était super de les
rencontrer et je les ai interviewés très
éprouvant pour les nerfs d'être un intervieweur ce n'est
pas quelque chose que je voudrais en faire une
habitude c'était beaucoup trop difficile
m'a donné un nouveau respect pour le journaliste
qui doit traverser ça mais ça
J'ai rencontré ces personnes et je
n'ai pas été déçu bien sûr j'étais
intéressé par des choses sur l'écriture en
savoir plus sur l'écriture donc beaucoup de
mes questions étaient orientées autour de th  au
sujet de toute évidence, les deux sont des idoles, l'
un d'eux a été amené dans une
situation qu'il ne pensait probablement pas
se produire de son vivant, même dans le bon
pays dans lequel il vivait, pourquoi
pensez-vous tout ce que vous savez ce qui vous vient à l'
esprit quand  vous voyez que les gens dans les
pays de l'Est en particulier l'
exécutif d'Ikea semblent ne pas être fasci
és par le disons Bush d'accord
tout compte fait cité
les États-Unis mais la loi très non offic
elle une fois une partie souterraine de l'Ét
t et bien
'est intéressant de voir en Tché
oslovaquie  à quel point les chansons signifiaient
pour eux parce que certainement mes chansons
parlent implicitement de la liberté d'expression
au moins cela et c'est ainsi qu'ils
ont été emmenés là-bas et ils ont eu
une répression si incroyable là-bas que
quelque chose à propos de la liberté d'expression
signifie vraiment beaucoup pour eux alors ils  êtes
très réceptif à quelque chose comme ça
serait certainement réceptif
aux politiques répressives régressives de
Reagan Bush dans lesquelles vous avez été
impliqué  ces dernières années avec Amnesty
International avec Greenpeace avec quatre ont
fait combien vous pensez vraiment qu'un
honnête peut gagner en dehors de son propre monde,
je veux dire que le travail réel ne repose pas sur
oricon sur tout ce qui peut vraiment
contribuer, vous savez, à ce type de
causes
bien  pense toujours à chacun pour soi Je
pense que chaque personne pourrait choisir si elle
trouve tout cela déroutant tant
d'avantages tant de causes tant d'
organisations c'est tellement impossible
laquelle est pour vous alors
vous n'en choisissez qu'une seule et vous seulement  opérer
pour celui-là, je dis en tant que personne privée,
vous pouvez simplement en choisir un et ce
serait suffisant dans ma situation parce que je suis une
célébrité au moins c'est une opportunité d'
utiliser la célébrité pour quelque chose ça doit
être bon pour quelque chose que je ne peux pas imaginer
pourquoi mais voilà voilà quelque chose en fait
que la célébrité est utile car elle
attire l'attention sur des causes qui que
c'est bien que c'est
bien qu'on attire l'attention donc c'est pour ça que je
fais ça et toi je veux dire le céle  brity
doit être bon pour quelque chose de plus que d'
avoir une bonne table dans un restaurant
rapidement tu sais qu'ils vont
écrire sur toi de toute façon si oh qu'as-
tu fait alors tu dis bien j'ai fait ça
nous sommes là
tu ressens ça  est quelque chose que vous tous
pour vous-même bien que vous devez
en fait bien essentiellement au grand
public oh je pense que tout le monde aimerait
faire quelque chose de positif et de bon avec
son temps ces choses ne prennent pas
tant que ça ce n'est pas difficile pour moi de faire ça
ça ne me demande pas grand-chose, donc
c'est un plaisir de pouvoir faire une
chose relativement petite qui
fait partie de quelque chose de positif
maintenant et qu'en est-il d'eux en fait,
je veux dire, c'est quelque chose que
disons que vous feriez de toute façon  ou continuer à
faire même s'il n'y avait pas de public
souligne bien que je ferais l'
écriture de toute façon mais si je n'avais pas de
public, je ne sais pas si je serais capable
de faire un disque ou de jouer avec un  groupe
je veux dire que j'écrirais en jeu de toute façon  mais
bien sûr, si vous n'avez pas de public, je
ne sais pas combien de temps vous pouvez jouer
gratuitement, surtout sans public, et
vous ne feriez certainement pas de disques à
moins que vous ne les ayez faits pour
vous-même et que vous les ayez gardés dans le placard, alors
je  pense que je suis très chanceux d'être dans la
position dans laquelle je suis en ce moment parce que je
pense que je me suis beaucoup amélioré
de différentes manières et je
commence juste à comprendre comment faire la
chose que je  faire mieux maintenant que jamais et
donc je pense que le nouvel album est un
reflet de cela, il est en avance sur
l'autre album, il fait vraiment partie
des trois derniers New York Drella maintenant celui-
ci, je pense que vous pourriez entendre
le  progression l'idée d'un
trou thématique commençant par un milieu et finissant une
augmentation de la sophistication de la technique de studio
parce que la production est un art en
soi et je pense que je travaille dans une
forme d'art relativement nouvelle qui est le CD
pendant une heure avec des paroles poétiques
sur le thème des adultes
connecté du début à la fin avec
bea  une musique utile et un très beau son
en même temps je veux dire une chanson je
veux dire c'est une vraie lune artistiquement pour
vous je veux dire cela inclut la
chanson de notre album parce que je veux dire je
suppose qu'il aurait été facile pour vous de
frapper un couple  plus tu sais donc New
York ouais ouais bien sûr je ne l'ai pas fait
donc c'est
non je ne voyais aucune raison de faire
quelque chose comme ça donc ça
m'intéresse d'avancer de ne pas répéter à
moins que l'itinéraire à moins d'être
répétitif fasse un  avancement, mais
tout ce que j'ai fait jusqu'à présent, ils essaient
de s'étirer et d'accord, l'agenda gauche au moins
conduit
ouais, alors qu'en est-il du fait
que nous avons besoin de toute évidence, vous grandissez
et vous êtes sur l'escrime et changez en tant
qu'artiste mais  évidemment, ce que vous avez fait
auparavant, ce que vous avez laissé derrière
semble rattraper l'imagination de beaucoup de gens
encore de nos jours, je veux dire qu'il est
impossible de compter les
groupes qui sonnent comme le Velvet Underground
qui arrivent, vous savez tous les jours quand je
voir être en France, en Angleterre, aux États-Unis, en
Australie ou ailleurs, alors je veux dire, qu'est-ce
que cela vous fait ressentir, vous savez peut-être que
lorsque vous en prenez un à la radio, vous
savez qu'il a fallu 25 ans pour que les gens
reconnaissent vraiment les
albums de Velvet Underground qui ont été faits  Il y a 25 ans,
j'espère qu'avec moi, ce n'est pas encore 25 ans
depuis que j'ai écrit tout le matériel pour le
Velvet Underground que ce n'est pas encore
25 ans pour arriver à mes albums aussi en ce
qui concerne les groupes qui sonnent comme The Velvet
Underground que je reçois, c'est tout  le temps
si c'est vrai, c'est très très
flatteur si certaines personnes semblent vouloir
monter le Yeon, c'est bien
parce que maintenant ils savent aussi que vous vous
promenez sur la couverture du côté sauvage chaque
semaine et parfois ce sont de grands succès
La marche de Marky Mark  du côté sauvage est un
succès beaucoup plus important,
désolé,
ne refais pas ça, c'est un succès beaucoup plus important
que mon côté sauvage ne l'a jamais été avec la promenade
du côté sauvage
qui est échantillonnée, ils doivent venir me
demander la permission  ou els  e Je les poursuis en justice,
il y en a tellement que c'est très très difficile
à contrôler, mais la marque de marquage
était celle que j'aimais et alors j'ai dit ouais
tu pouvais le faire j'aime un peu tous
ces jeunes enfants qui courent autour de l'échantillonnage des
choses
des choses intéressantes qu'ils peuvent faire avec
et c'est assez amusant, le
ferez-vous, je veux dire quelques-uns si vous
débutiez tous de nos jours, c'est que la
façon dont vous sortiriez de la musique oh je ne sais pas
je veux dire je suis un guitariste  vous savez que
je le ferais, je ne sais pas si c'est le genre de
chose dans laquelle je serais impliqué, mais je pense que
la façon dont certaines personnes l'utilisent comme un outil est
vraiment amusante tant qu'elles attribuent le mérite aux
personnes à qui elles le prennent et le font
avec leur permission, je pense qu'il est très
important qu'ils créditent la personne
qu'ils échantillonnent, mais vous eh bien, il y a un
excellent moyen pour des enfants comme eux de monter de
petites productions entières juste hors
échantillonnage avec un client appelé question
probablement c'était quelques-uns d'entre eux un  écoute
ouais c'est le business juste sur un camion
appelé
mmm au moins une entreprise écoute bien
sans entrer dans quoi que ce soit de ce que Tribe
Called Quest sort de New
York, je pense qu'ils sont l'un des meilleurs
mais comme je l'ai dit, il échantillonne, ils doivent
vous donner du crédit,
je ne peux pas simplement  même si vous vous éloignez, l'
une des choses intéressantes est
qu'il devient de plus en plus clair maintenant
pour deux personnes qui regardent votre travail qu'en
fait, même si vous êtes très
cochon, ne jouez pas et depuis l'ère du rock,
vous voyez aussi de plus en plus  appartenir à une
sorte de cette tradition d'
écrivain américain qui peut durer beaucoup plus loin au cours
du siècle mais qui inclut des gens que
vous savez bien écrire et interpréter
leurs propres écrits et leur poésie comme l'ont
fait les poètes The Beat par exemple, c'est
écouter la tradition de c'est  que
ce que vous ressentez, il y a un lien
juste parce que j'y pense
évidemment à cause du livre et aussi
du fait qu'il devrait être enseigné, je veux dire
que vous avez lu tout ce que j'ai
fait pendant une heure et demie p
lectures d'interprétation du livre c'est très bien
passé fabuleux vraiment super très
intéressant d'interagir avec le
public de cette façon donc je suppose qu'il
serait possible de voir comment cela remonte à une
tradition dont vous pourriez
parler des poètes lisant dans les années 50 mon
le point est que pour mes chansons j'essaie d'avoir des
paroles qui sont de la poésie en premier
lieu et qui peuvent être indépendantes de la musique
le livre est une démonstration de ce
principe donc mais c'est génial de combiner
le tout et le son parce que
j'aime tellement le son  beaucoup c'est le son et les
mots ensemble
et puis c'est aussi je pense
juste à laisser tomber la musique parfois
ce que j'ai remarqué, c'est que certaines paroles sont
beaucoup plus drôles mais aussi certaines paroles
sont beaucoup plus dures sans la musique
qu'elles devaient obtenir  vous en avez fini avec eux
parce que sans la musique là-bas, c'est
tout ce que vous entendez d'autres mots donc vous ne pouvez pas le
manquer parfois avec la musique là-bas,
vous ne remarquerez peut-être pas étant donné que
ces mots ont été écrits en ac  être
chanté et interprété avec de la musique, ce qui
signifie qu'avec un peu de vous, avez-vous déjà
été tenté d'être un peu comme un blanc
vous les lisiez un peu comme
les rapper, je veux dire étant
donné que ces mots ont été écrits pour être
convoqués  être joué avec le rythme
derrière eux non mais ils sont également écrits
pour être autonomes ils ont été écrits avec
l'idée en premier lieu que s'il
n'y avait pas de musique là-bas, ils pourraient
se tenir debout sur leurs deux pieds sur lesquels ils
n'avaient pas à dépendre  la musique alors
j'y mets de la musique mais même avec la
sagesse ça ne te donne pas
évidemment l'écriture tu connais une
raison qu'ils doivent ils doivent bien se remettre
j'ai un rythme en premier lieu
bien quand tu lis  vous pouvez jouer
avec le rythme différents rythmes
parce que vous n'avez pas à garder le temps sur un
tambour afin que vous puissiez développer cette
pensée rythmique donc ce qui donne les battements alors
le battement est dans les mots c'est en fait
le battement est dans la personne qui les lit
agir aussi quand  en faisant la lecture, vous
pouvez entendre les différentes voix dans une
parole, ce n'est pas toujours juste fait, ce sont toutes
des personnes différentes qui parlent dans les paroles
et vous pouvez entendre le jeu ou, espérons-le,
vous ne le considérez pas comme un jeu, vous pensez simplement
à tout cela différemment  voix vous l'
acceptez quelle est l'attente habituelle du public à
votre égard quand ils sont venus
et vous savez juste pour nous les lire
Je pense que le public savait qu'il
venait à une lecture et qu'il
faudrait qu'il soit le plus beau public que
vous puissiez imaginer je  pense qu'ils savaient que
ce serait une expérience différente et
qu'ils étaient prêts à se donner
pour cela et c'était l'un des moments forts
de ma vie les lectures surtout à
New York ma maison Missy
pouvez-vous déplacer l'éclairage